okay for those joining our livestream
this is a meeting about a curious topic
um we want to represent everything about
the world in Wolfram language and among
the things we have to represent are
things like phone numbers and people's
names and so on so this is the story
okay
so the concept here is to introduce a
phone number rapper that will be the
return from interpreter phone number the
default returned from interpreter phone
number is that correct by the way we
have a bunch of background noise can you
mute that please
um yes yeah so it would be a function
that it's able to take a string parse it
as much as possible and then typeset it
nicely so so our concept here is that we
would have something much like would it
be like who so let me give an analogy I
mean is it like date object where I
could say you know but can I do this yes
I can't do that and the output contains
things a rate I've said it's already
prepared so that typesetting works
faster right but so what we've done in
this case is it just looks like that
I mean arguably this should be an
association inside a lot of background
noise Jose I don't know quite why like
wind noise type type thing um anyway go
ahead yes so important thing is to have
a canonical form whatever it is and and
the difficult part is to have a parser
which is able to canonicalize things
right now why didn't that work
precisely that they'd string parsing is
quite difficult so it has limitations
will we know that but on the other hand
if I say control equals noon Jan first
why don't we loop this through the
external pause or if we have to in a
case like that and by the way why did
this come back as a date object that
looks like that rather than coming back
as a why does it I mean that that is the
correct was
but but yes so that's the older notation
so ya could come back directly as their
new input form did it update to a newer
notation yes it did yeah it looks fine
so if I okay right so with respect to
phone numbers what are we doing and
control equals what do we do with phone
numbers that's interesting it knew what
that was huh
that's a weird assuming it knew what it
was but it did I mean it did something
obviously knew that was a phone number
otherwise it wouldn't have parenthesized
the area code I don't quite understand
what that did and that should probably
be that should certainly be cleaned up
this referring to special numbers is
totally weird also I note the presence
of an extra space tie which is a bug
okay fine so let's go back to phone
number doesn't pull alpha for phone
numbers so basically what we did with
with Sara is that we is the library
which is standard for the industry and
internally we get a lot more information
then we spit out and so I think it would
be a great idea to actually have a
wrapper and the only reason we're not
exposing with the other information that
we get is is that we didn't have a
wrapper okay fine just design it I mean
there are at least like one is the one
you're seeing now this is more like a
machine one the one you are outputting
now yes like according to you know like
counters and stuff
there is also like a default you
readable format that is using dashes and
parentheses sure which is which varies
for both the parentheses not what is
that background please um
parentheses I'm not so keen on the
dashes seem useful I mean I don't think
I think even in the US that the
parentheses for area codes this
definitely looks a bit dated these days
what do people think anybody's got an
opinion Alan you have an opinion not a
strong one I guess I agree with
parentheses don't seem quite as standard
these days because nobody can do can you
even do ok this shows my utter naivete
my lack of actual communication with the
direct phone system who has a landline
where you're calling a lot of people who
are in the same area code but can you
still do that you can you can dial in
like an air echo - 1 7 you can doll
without an area code if it's low if it's
in the same area code is that true or
not I haven't had a landline in more
than a decade so I have no idea
does anybody on this cool name in the US
but here you have to dial usually
without the area code if you are in the
same area I can tell you that in Italy
there has been a big campaign where when
cell phones are being popular and which
force is always everyone to add the area
code it's been like 15 years ago so you
can basically all right so look we
shouldn't come the okay so apparently in
Pennsylvania you have to use an area
code even if you're calling across the
street is that true in in Illinois and -
Ericka - 1 7 or not who knows anyway the
fact that none of us I just tried it on
my phone right now and it automatically
added a area code ok um alright so I
think we should assume that we're just
using the dashes notation no parentheses
I think this is old-school um as the
default output let me just um save this
an external reference
um
you
you
okay so somebody is
um yeah okay um okay plus for one oh I
see okay okay okay okay so you're saying
this is from documentation for live
phone number yeah this is good so this
makes perfect sense so that's the
standard international format within the
country it's that what what the heck is
that that's from like Italy or something
right because within the UK that will be
zero six six eight
what are we even talking UK for one is
swear is for one Switzerland yeah this
is wis yes through Thailand um so I have
no idea what that looks like with in
Switzerland okay that that's plausible
for what it looks like with in
Switzerland
um yeah indeed here for example for for
regional let's say calling you need to
add the zero so that's very common and
that's usually there's also the always
used to be the case there was the notion
of an entry code an exit code for
countries but maybe the exit code like
in the u.s. if you want to dial you know
knots on a cell phone you would dial
zero-one-one
and then the country code in number the
people know that or is that like like
ancient history now yeah I knew that
and here for example was zero zero so so
yes in each place you have a different
international exit code that's right
right okay all right fine whatever you
can ask for the format that phone for
that country you know because here there
are like all phone for matters for each
country okay in the slip following thing
apparently Wikipedia also has a big page
for this
let me just look at the what they have
to say about this
hey and we also have stuff that we
currently don't extract but who should
probably extract like can it receive as
a masses and stuff like that yes that
would be useful okay fine um all right
terrific so all right so let's just
agree what this thing is gonna look like
so it's going to it's going to be say
phone number and then it's going to be
an association so they're two issues we
have what what the phone number
association looks like and what and then
we can make queries into the Association
to do various things and then what the
what the print form looks like and I
think the print form should be I would
suggest it's this international
form like this because that makes it or
should we do it the same way we do time
zones where if it's within the country
it formats in a national way I kind of
think we should standardize on this um
the only other question is whether if
it's not within the country whether the
phone number should say what country
it's in in the formatted form and we're
making sense
anybody want to comment or not there is
a further issue I mean if you are not
providing like a prefix to this rapper
then the library I don't know what to do
but but but you can specify a default
one that of course from the band on your
yeah I mean look what I'm saying is that
if you are in the u.s. probably makes
sense
this is already with each other I think
you can try like right now right but the
same call you had the ball with with
interpreter you can move once one and
I'm sure it'll do the right thing but
what happens if I was relocated in some
other country what I'm saying is that we
need to have a way to specify like a
country if you want to enjoy this
country you know what I think that what
we can do is that we can have a default
constructor for phone numbers that's
just a string that does whatever
interpreter does if you don't provide
the restriction or you can you can put
in country goes to blah or prefix close
to blah or either called actually it's
important as well and then and then we
flesh out the Association by taking that
as the as the restriction
that's fine um probably we should
support and control equals we should
support things about um you know phone
number in country X and so on alright so
so just to understand I should look at
the Lib phone number I mean we probably
don't need to go through all of this
right now um it's um wait a minute why
am i ok so highlights of functionality
okay Oh gets a confidence level on
whether two numbers could be the same
Wow
um
okay provides geographic information
related to a phone number to carry a
mapper okay two time zones that's
interesting so it Maps so it has a way
so for example things like this should
probably work local time a phone number
am I making sense
just like local time of United States I
don't know what it does actually find
out what it does
um what does it do that's a little weird
why does it pick GMT - for it probably
is resorting to a default position for
the US okay
I mean if you do a position of the
United States or United States well we
think it would give someone in Kansas
which wouldn't be dream t-minus four III
think we are the fault into the largest
city for countries okay okay okay okay
fair enough
um okay but so that should work and
presumably find geolocation of a phone
number should work
yeah I don't know how precise it can be
I don't know yeah it's not very precise
well I mean what I'm saying is that I
don't think they have metadata that go
beyond the national level so okay but we
have it for area codes in the u.s. not
that it really means anything anymore
with cell phones but but I mean we have
all the detailed information for all the
area codes right some fish for landlines
might make sense but for cell phones
right now I think it's nationalize
anywhere oh yeah somebody's also kind of
very sensibly on the live stream how
will phone number handle extensions
extensions are such a can of worms well
and what does what does he do right now
if you type I don't know 444 after there
splat okay so I mean the other question
is things where it goes into dialing
what if you remove the X because I think
reading something that I read something
that annotations saying that in some
countries extra like letters are ignored
so okay hold on cell phone so one of the
issues is tension numbers slash dialing
conventions
okay and we've clearly got some funky
ones like like I mean we've got all
kinds of corner cases like my Sat phone
which has a three digit um you know eg
satphones with with not with no country
code also I think specials phones I
don't know if we want to represent them
for example operators usually have a
specialist phone like one two three four
calling the the operator seems like that
they still have an operator I don't even
know what happens and services all those
kinds of good things I mean yeah right
like in the US for one one three one one
nine one one etc if for example here
that they put backwards they one nine as
one one six for emergency okay um well
that's a separate completely separate
issue which I wonder whether we have
that date removed now for the emergency
numbers for different countries if we
don't we should put that in it seems
useful seems useful um okay uh let's see
someone on the live stream is saying
that a phone number has a perspective
whether it is a local number or an
out-of-area number I'm not sure if
that's a concept really um the haha yes
it would be nice if there's a way to ask
the language how to dial a number from a
specific location I agree so because the
issue here okay so let's first of all
let's think about the the actual
Association that we have here okay so um
could we where is the thing can somebody
show me from this lib phone number or
whatever it is thing what um I mean I'm
seeing here a bunch of description about
um get phone number able to distinguish
fixed line mobile toll-free etc okay so
so that presumably becomes a okay so
there's presumably a number type or just
a type
those kinds of things canonicalized
that's part of and I wonder whether in
the print form that should be displayed
some of those things
anybody got an opinion about that okay
so we've got we've got the pure how do
we bright the number inside this
association what is there a canonical
way to do that provided by this
somebody respond please
and that's me mostly these things come
out of job ads all caps strings okay
what are the strings what are the
elements of the Association I mean it
depends what we ask fit no no I
understand but what does it generate
what what's okay what does it generate
for
yeah so okay so there's the failure case
right failure case should be things like
you know failure
um you know not a valid phone number
format and that should be something that
those failures right in the case of a
forum should be the things that come out
you know as the messages make sense
yes
I think so but we have to be very sure
that it's it's a wrong number
not number with an offer to pose I
understand I understand we're getting
get to that I I assume that this library
does a pretty good job of non extension
number numbers right okay so can we
could you just generate what whatever
the
[Music]
should I think the question will be what
are the properties of this so the thing
is that since it's not necessarily
property some of these things or methods
so it's not like actually most of these
these things are methods so it's not
free like a glance reports the number
it's not necessarily free to get another
stuff out ok fine it's reasonably fast
so I mean it's not calling an external
service or any it's just a Java library
ultimate the data is local so
okay
okay it's interesting that there are
claim that phone numbers have only one
prefix at a given time
that's very weird um okay
apparently there's a testing thing here
specify a phone number okay specified
default country specify a carrier code
okay
you
to letter country code us okay
you
you
okay
okay
is valid short number is possible short
number
fix line or mobile great that's useful
um what happens if i type in okay here's
another question
you can for example for you yeah well
hold on what happens if I type that they
work okay so that that's something we
should document but that would things
like that work I think I love totally
sure that we actually allow it right now
but okay well so hold on hold on hold on
corner cases are spelled numbers now
let's see if we allow it so we have an
interpreter here
nope okay so that's another thing to
worry about um okay so they're various
types here which will include things
like toll free fixed or mobile which
appears to be a necessary thing etc okay
so the question is okay so we'll need
something which is kind of a e.164
I guess version I mean we can just put a
bunch of things in this association I
think you should because in string
string okay because yeah yeah that makes
sense and that will be plus 1 2 1 7 etc
etc ok then we need a way to give the
local thing the local string whatever
that should be um I mean all national no
I understand I understand but but it
seems according to those fa Q's it was
pointing out that there is a necessarily
a single national string um but I mean
we could say national string
international string why not national
number international number well because
they are a string I guess the thing is
that yeah I sure because you need this
he risks of course but right um okay
well so something like this so now um
and then the accesses for this thing
well then then we also need something
that says country
do we want a break for fing down into a
country code and the number
I think it will be useful to have the
country code there because many times
you need to do something special with
the country code if you want to pull
from for example paid operator so you
know yeah but okay the country code well
so then then we've got country country
which is an entity country code which is
something like plus one plus whatever
well you think it's plus one or it's
it's some one of these guys okay which
either that or it's for for its you know
yeah you're right without the blast free
yeah
and it's actually the country code could
be an integer
I think so
thing to worry about um then ah okay so
in the first approximation we got these
things now how do you get I think we
probably have region if we know it
and there's also these things about
whether or not Congress SMS and so on if
that's if we can if we can figure that
out
so okay you guys should work out the
details of this but I think um let's
talk about extension numbers for a
second and I don't know what to do with
the country the case of country for
satphones extensions because I can we
talk for a second about satphones please
about about non about country entities
that aren't countries and what we do
well we have the world entity or we will
have some missing not applicable for
them and also make them ballot to be I
think it's better yeah
um
you
yes such something out I've stream
plates our country calling code would be
a probably about a name for that um okay
missing satellite phone so slightly
bizarre case of missing but informative
okay let's talk about a potential
numbers and then you can hear my beef
for that extension numbers I mean the
fact is there are two issues one is um
the just recording an extension number
and the other is being able to dial the
extension number alright so you know in
the old-fashioned world of putting
commas and phone numbers to generate
pauses right that's the convention that
started off with modems calling numbers
autodialers and so on
um I mean for our purposes okay so
question like the Twilio interface for
instance um what can one put into the
1200 interface come on put extension
numbers into the Twilio interface
anybody no yes like if I want to call
somebody's extension tour from nearly
like dial it all at once with the
extension or dressed wait you have to
wait and I mean we happen to have a
direct inward dialing mechanism but in
general you have to wait and and for
example our internal VoIP phone system
for amazingly still after all these
years does not have the ability to code
in delays you know pauses like that
which means that when you dial the you
know conference phone bridge thing you
actually have to dialer an out of foam
which is infuriating um but I mean in
most of the world you put a comma in
together pause if I don't know how long
it is I mean as far as when you're
calling suppose I'm trying to hold a big
public office like I just call a normal
number when I want to get the extension
and the son central phone when I want to
talk to an operator and ask for an
extension is shorter than most phones so
like extensions extensions don't really
exist as such that's really weird that's
really wait we do avi is accepting
accent extension so how does it by them
I'm not sure if it's part of the topic
directly but basically what is doing is
that you it does the number and anyways
that is started using basically
emulating the a person dialing the
exception so he's waiting for the actual
phone to the gap yes but I bet it has
some waiting convention because you know
normally is put you put commas in so the
question for us here is should we have I
forget what those things are called they
were
[Music]
let's see um
you know what's interesting that
everybody seems to have a
yeah everybody is is using okay so
there's a two-second a comma appears to
be a two second pause
and there seems to be a semicolon which
means wait for something maybe wait for
a dial tone
oh no note that that's an on-screen
prompt but I think there's also a wait
for a dial tone
mechanism these are
let's see gosh
okay well again we need to some somebody
probably in the sysadmin group probably
knows this okay hold on a second send
digits attribute tells Twilio to send
DTMF tones when the call is answered
okay but that there will be something I
don't know whether it's this equals wait
for dial tone
incidentally one of those curious things
that we could add to Wolf's malphur
would be what the ring - ringing tone
sounds like in different countries that
would be an amusing audio identify thing
to have you know what I'm saying
like you call a country you could
typically tell what country person with
a cell phone is in because you will get
the local ringtone ringing sound of that
country people know what I'm talking
about yeah but I think it's hopeless
I've seen vanity ring like internal
ringtones like you could really yeah
like cell phone company would let you
like play this music when okay fine okay
all right here they put publicity really
yes okay fine forget that idea all right
um okay what are we gonna do with
extension numbers I mean in I think what
we should do
probably sorry a related thing with the
music there's a cell that you do when
you type on the on the keys I don't know
if they are the same with all the phones
what the DTMF code tones the thing that
one or two or three two different yes
yes yes those that those are two tones
that was invented by Bell Labs back in
the day I'm pretty sure it's the same
everywhere um we could do something that
converts I don't know yeah that will be
cute to have a DTMF and I don't think
anybody cares anymore back when there
were things people cared a lot but Tim
now I think that's that's old news
all right so extension um again roughly
what we might do then what are we gonna
do we've got to canonicalize an
extension somehow right how does it come
out canonically if you type in a phone
number with an extension right so let's
say I type in some phone number with an
extension
um
like this then how what is the canonical
way that it should come out
anybody got an opinion about this
I think the group of people in this call
may not be the best ones to answer this
question but I think we need some way to
I mean are we going to process the phone
number and then look for an X or an ext
or you know their variety of different
linguistics that one can use to specify
an extension right there can also be
commas that literally are specifying the
the pauses
oh boy apparently hash sign also used to
specify an extension okay so look my
suggestion is that we parse this thing
hmm yeah I think we have to parse it
into these things that are separately
the you know international numbers
string and the extension and the
extension will will basically just be
what would it end up being I mean it
should be canonicalized to something
which has pauses followed by followed by
digits to dial am I making sense
yes unless there is some local way of
presenting it but I think for example
having the coma and then a white space
and then the number will be a nice way
to analyze because it's something you
can understand that there is some kind
of extra number you have to dial after
the number yes that's fine I mean I
think that but okay so let me make it
one more point here which is these
valency numbers like come where do we do
we keep the vanity number if you type in
you know I mean in our phone number did
you get what I'm saying it that that um
okay so we could arguably say display
string okay which would include things
like the you know 1-800 wolfram number
does that make sense in other words we
would preserve that if we know we can if
we because you know if you want if you
type that in you probably want to
preserve that form comments I mean I I
think does the right thing when you ask
for whatever string version you get you
get the I mean if you look back at that
web page okay I won't know if it could
have acute things that would generate
some strings that looks good given a
phone number I don't know if it's any
maybe nobody cares what doing the weave
operation like you have a number and
then gives a string that you know with
both loop oh yeah we've had that that's
a cute
there's demonstrations and things that
would be it's a fine function repository
entry they have a suggestion on a live
stream to do things like this which yeah
I mean that's definitely relevant look I
think we have to just play around with
this extension thing um
pointing out that this is actually your
right this is the input string not the
UM I don't know whether it's the display
string or the input string I mean it yes
arguably it is the input string so so we
should maybe keep the input string so
how the user either which is different
from the final display I think right
okay all right that's enough for phone
numbers I think we have what we need to
go ahead and start implementing this
agreed one one more question
so I'm worried about localization
because if I if I create one of these
phone number objects when I'm in Spain
then I can I use it when I mean in the
US okay that's a really good question
because like time zone it has it has to
do the same thing that data object does
with time zone I think right well time
Soames is independent of the country
what it was created no I understand that
but if you create if you make a now on
your computer and then you move your
computer it will correctly know what the
time was when you created that now
because it will burn in I mean if I do
that right here right it will burn in in
the input form it will burn in timezone
- for exactly right so but here we are
already adding this country calling
codes so that's I think fine yeah we
need to make sure that it has enough
country independent information so that
it can recover anywhere well right but
the question is within a country okay so
let's talk about the display format um
no you see this isn't right because
national number string might be the
originating national number is it the
current national number string
or the string in the originating country
see I mean in other words what should
happen is when you ask for the phone
number it figures out what country
you're in when you're asking for the
phone number it then burns in that
country it then knows that that yo I'm
saying I mean arguably national number
string should not be generated should be
computed every time based on what
country you're actually in or is that
the the the number string that you would
dial within the country that the thing
happens to be in you get what I'm saying
if you have a number that's in Spain for
example and you type it in when you're
in Spain and then you come to the US
then the question is what would you dial
in order to actually get to the phone
number
what do you dial deep because if you're
in Spain you don't want to dial the
international number string okay so
arguably we want something else that's
called dial a bull dial a bull string
dialing string and that would also deal
with things like extension numbers you
know string for dialing from the country
you're in but I'm not sure that should
be a that sumi for for an accessor
probably because you want to form that
no I understand that's an accessor
that's not I mean it could be generated
and put in the in the Association
because it's cheap to generate
am I making sense
okay so that could be confusing if you
already have that there I think why I
mean if you well whatever okay access or
only question mark okay you guys need to
work through more details of this
because we need to go on to the next
topic um okay so our next topic is
personal names right
well or do we want to shoot we talk
about physical addresses or should we
talk about personal names perhaps
addresses are easy I really think so um
okay I mean I don't know why you think
this is the right thing I mean even in
England for example a very common thing
in England at least back in the day was
names of houses which is not listed in
here
these this is the average format that
they Wikipedia page gives then it lists
all the variants for every country it's
a very long list okay but so what this
is I mean what is the use case for this
so I mean the the use case is that we
just want a way of storing an address
where it is easy to where it's easy to
extract pieces so what do we want to
have work on this geolocation should
work on a physical address accesses like
physical address um
you by the way you still have really
weird background noise I think it's you
Jose now we don't hear that so I think
there's a bug in something to do with
the way you're connected ok so then um
other things should you be able to do
for physical address you should be able
to know country you should be able to
know city etc but what else do we want
to be able to do with the physical
address
ultimately well okay you want some some
kind of display form of the thing um you
know you want a a address label
basically which would be the things
stacked in a way that would be suitable
for an address label um
what else in the first line you mean
find your location right rather than
geolocation
I don't see why geolocation shouldn't
work I mean it's an option right now is
your location not a function I didn't
mean your location I meant to your
position your position sorry
and by the way geolocation should be an
option up here with phone numbers if you
say you know you know if you say phone
number so you say phone number of blah
blah blah
geolocation arrow Switzerland for
example it should interpret that phone
number with geolocation Switzerland that
you fully stolen see location that is
correct yes
so that phone number so in the unlikely
event that you give in the US a phone
number without an area code it should be
able to do something there although I
frankly I think that's a luxury
makes sense
yes and and our default just to be clear
our default display um would say
something like um phone number
what are we going to do we'd say it's
like a date object it would be an object
there and I'll be good with a little
phone icon and then you know +1 -
whatever makes sense by the way the
other thing that was in there which we
should have is carrier if known
um now I don't know how we canonicalize
them and there we're going to need we're
gonna need entity canonicalization for
carriers company data maybe yeah it's
basically company data although there
may be finer gradations for carriers I
don't know what the different brands of
one company um are you know are
separated and also something that might
be interesting to have for example
hearing we have a couple of couriers
that are sharing all Latin America and
with me we want to analyze them a
different way then use a company yes
it's a single it's a single network
right
yeah and for example now some of these
carriers are starting to to allow calls
between different countries without any
extra international fee for example okay
oh by the way interpreter apparently
already uses um cheer location so that's
good for for um for these things
a question is whether oh boy I mean in a
luxury case right we could have
something about um you know well you
know what what is the is does it count
as an international call etc I have no
idea whether that's I don't know idea
whether that's at all algorithmically
determinable um alright let's go on
because we need to I'm probably not for
the US because I think plus one is
shared with Mexican calendar and that's
correct
yes sander is pointing out that in Japan
addresses a much more complicated I mean
what what are we trying to do with
physical address we're trying to get
something where we can break the pieces
of address apart like this is it the
case that our geo coder will do that
does the geo coder do that if I say find
geolocation is there a stage at which it
knows I mean that's probably just gonna
give me a location right but is there a
stage at which it knows what the
subparts of that address are
I think yes they try to parse and they
have more information than the one that
we specify all right and why don't you
look into that and why don't you see
whether we can actually get pieces like
this um oh that's an interesting point
somebody's making that that can we
generate the bark postal barcode yeah
that's an interesting thing um I don't
know those are I'm sure those are
country specific
code and then there would be for the
extra luxury this postal barcode
um all right let's talk for a minute
about names and see just how it so I
think the next step with this is go find
out what our geolocation capabilities
are in terms of parsing addresses make
sense
just one question I mean physical
address in the Wikipedia refers to
computer memory addressing so do you
think of her physical address is the
right name or would you like to call it
geographic address Geo dress perhaps
living there is something like I think
in interpret school street address yes
but what if you're I mean okay so
there's I think it's a little weird to
call it street address at this level
goog
yo this is moral it's better sweet icing
because street address to a specific
degree all right so geo address would be
then so we're thinking of calling it geo
address not physical address
you
I mean geo address physical address I
mean okay so then the idea for geo
address like like a university for
example where there's a you know
you know again then there's a building
name right typically and often there
isn't a a street
you know an external postal street
address
makes sense so I guess yeah I mean I
assume that what we do here is that the
canonical print form of geo address will
be just some nice I won't be an address
label it'll just be some nice I'm not
sure again
let's find out what we can do with the
current Jill geolocation Jo coder okay
let's talk about personal names okay um
so what are you
so there are a bunch of horrific things
here um so what is your what is your
conclusion about this um but it's
complicated
yeah exactly there are many
possibilities right um okay
yes western name or the eastern name
order there has to be the you know the
whole zoo of Latin American names and
their orderings right
yes right patronymic s'en iceland and so
on
fine okay so there's a there's a lovely
posting apparently about fall suits
programmers believe about names people's
names do not change yeah yeah yeah
right
when I applied for Social Security name
in England they asked to me for all my
previous names that was very funny
that's interesting that is an
interesting question as previous names
is actually something I mean being able
to have that ability to store those will
be useful right because that's you know
people you know whether used to be you
know maiden names and listen that
neither um but if we have a notion of
previous names um okay so what are we
basically gonna try to do here first of
all do we have what is our ability to
parse names at this time what what what
by the way there's princes very good
example of former names yes that one is
I mean the Prince glyph is just that's
beyond hopeless I think um I think it
has to be you know assume all names a
Unicode
but yeah but there is a there is another
thing is that like why would we parse
means like what this falsehoods blah
blah blah says is that you can't even
assume that first-name lastname so of
course yeah that's right that the reason
that we want to do this is for
canonicalization it's it's important
that for example many people think that
I have three first name and one last
name why I have two first names and two
last names and it will be great if I
can't her wire in some notation that
what is the true thing but even
romanization if you ask me Tommy
his romanization changed when Ukraine
became trained because the romanization
changes between Russian and Ukrainian
law like they don't have the same
alphabet here yeah right right I suspect
the end of his first name is different
there um okay but I mean our main goal
here is you know canonical
representation because what we want to
be able to do is I mean do we know what
happens in in things like you know iOS
there is some canonicalization in the
contact database I think it's very
simple isn't it I mean I think it's
basically just or do you just type the
name in however you feel like
actually I think you just type the name
in however you feel like
but you know the problem for us as we've
been through about 25 times is
recognizing you know like what happens
you know in the the the contact database
part of Siri where you can give a
subpart of a name and it will pick up
the that complete name because it knows
that there's a limited set of possible
names am i making sense
right so plus well I don't know is with
Alan light to comment on personal name
and its relationship to people data I
I'm I'm not sure I mean we I don't think
that we even expose separate given name
and surname properties for people in
people data precisely because we'd have
to kind of figure out case by case and
country by country what the which which
slot is correct to stick each name into
sorry what were you just saying we don't
expose in people data so if I say who's
got a window name let's try um let's try
I don't know let's try now okay
there's no no given name or surname
property for a person there's just name
okay so our full-name we have fun yeah
well I bet that's not a full name why
would you think that's a full name or we
have a property called full name no I
mean we only have like one full name not
separated by properties all right um
okay but but so if you give I have no
idea but I mean let's just try something
like that I have no idea whether the
full name there is some I don't think
the phone yeah okay
it's a patronymic yes if the mere name
is a patronymic in russian yes yeah yeah
yeah what give me a name of somebody a
Latin American name
somebody people data
Petra Burrill I could spell
come on we got along there right there
like Mario Barroso you know okay but
what if that Mario what no it seems try
bosses for example okay okay my gosh
what a mess which which name here oh my
gosh what a mess so work is his father's
last name as availably his molar last
name and all the others are his name's
right for heat first names to pseudonyms
my gosh okay um pointing out on the live
stream
okay um so let's see what does that do
if we ask for full name
interesting okay so so fundamentally
we've used strings to it so far
and
I mean there's okay maybe we should try
to solve the problem of name matching
before we try to solve the problem of
name canonicalization
or maybe that's hopeless as well I mean
that the case that I've been you know
been talking about forever is the case
where you say you know mr. Smith um
Mary Smith
[Music]
you know I don't know we could say here
James Smith okay
etc so the question is who you know
who's the same as who
right which you need for any kind of
contact look up and you also need for
mailing lists canonicalization all those
kinds of things
I think it has hopefully snow days so
it's something that everybody does
including us including you know we're
even required to do that for GDP our
compliance and all kinds of crazy things
like that
yeah like think about the fact that
there are some languages were the last
name changes gender
according to like like sure Russian for
example
so what's your point that it's very very
hard to do in general I know but so we
have to figure out what piece of this
that look there's a piece of
functionality that one clearly needs
which is given a list of names you know
given a list of canonical target names
match this list of incoming names with
that list of target names am I making
sense
and you know right now there are all
kinds of machine learning based
solutions to doing this that use various
kinds of context information
incidentally I don't even think we have
the case for email addresses um and and
we've never done we've never actually
made a wrapper for email address have we
so that's another thing we should
consider because one of the issues with
email address is the same
canonicalization thing I mean in other
words if I am you know if I'm on the one
hand you know suave at you know swole
foot right calm versus you know well
even you know suave at mail dot Wolfram
calm I don't think I that any of those
may work but anyway the the you know
being able to figure out whether those
are the same or not which maybe can't be
done without communicator in the mail
server I'm not sure but some of these
things like these prefixes are um you
know there's the question of can you
tell whether that prefix is unnecessary
no but III think that's let's say all
school because now you have only the
email addresses and and not this
internal all server others that were
used before I haven't seen that you know
I okay fair enough
well then then we should declare victory
on something like that yeah there's
people on a live stream and pointing out
all kinds of other horrifying cases for
names like Henry the eighth's what an
earth is that what is the full name and
I'm really curious
huh I think I'll and you that the name
of Spanish king by the way regarding why
didn't that work that was at least as a
ship or something Wow Oh Spanish king I
sent it in ancient okay
you
that's that's
okay um well so what's your conclusion
with these this name is business is
important sorry to me the important
thing is to be able to specify the
structure now if we have functions which
are able to take a name and create that
structure that would be great as well
but the disambiguation part is important
well so you you're proposing that what
are you proposing you're proposing last
names arrow and then a list of names for
example all the last names always given
in the same order they're not aren't
they and don't they flip around that the
mother's versus father's last name in
different Latin American countries no
but once you have one order that's it
till they use smaller fathering mostly I
use father oh I see but don't you want
to know okay so so then then you have an
additional I'm not even going to start
thinking about the modern the modern
world of you know same-sex couples and
God knows what else and what it means
when you have I'm not even that let's
not even let's not even try going there
I know idea as other known conventions
for that now most countries that's
that's for the future somehow the okay
because that's okay because then that
will prevent that canonicalization okay
so um but then for example like last
names like our you know well they're
people like in the British were you know
thing there are double-barreled last
names how this is a huge mess well
what's what's your point Jose you you
you are proposing that it will be nice
if if there is a structure to give if
there is an Owen structure to be able to
represent that structure but then if you
have the structure rendering it in a you
know dear so-and-so type form in a in a
salutation for example seems um you know
that seems super difficult well I guess
I mean I don't really have a good test
case because you know I get all kinds of
weird spam mail that says you know dear
Steven thought but my name is
exceptionally straightforward so I'll be
more interested in somebody like
Francisco what the corresponding things
what what they do for you whether they
get it right or whether they're just
utterly wrong the automatic is spam
usually is wrong but and also for
example in the u.s. usually they use my
second last name for referring us if it
were the first which is problematic in
many places and then but of course in
Latin America it's usually usually right
because right that's why I use a hyphen
outside Spain and in fact in England in
that discussion they decided that my
name without the hyphen was my previous
name you name as two words yes Martin
Garcia are two separate words but
outside the Spain I put a hyphen in
between so that people believe it's one
only oh gosh okay
recap this last name wasn't picked up
correctly by our own system so I think
the important thing is to separate first
names from last names because it's very
common to sort people by alphabetically
by last names
yeah if we can know which one is which
one I think that would happen or seems
to be already right so I was wondering
if we could have I put that in the so
for example for Boris that you have
previously there something that could
pass something like this will make sense
for me and useful yeah but there is an
ordering your point is there is a there
is an ordering for these names
so the the fact that you give first
they're given names and then the last
names or first the last name then the
given names I think it's something you
can so so they the usual order here is
used give first they're given names and
then the last name but for example for
phone books usually give order by last
name so so they put for example the last
name coma they given names right look I
think someone on the chart is pointing
out I mean that's just names are a huge
mess I mean they contain names of places
they contain things whether it's just a
single name and it's not you know where
it's I've known people who just have one
name not a not a given name not a last
name just a single name um seems to
happen in places like Pakistan I think
um okay look it's it's clearly a hugely
complicated mess so the issue is and
what we've done for you know notable
people entities seems fairly sensible
here although I have no idea if I were
to say if I were to type in something
like um I bet we don't get this right
but let's see whether we do
you
we do fascinating what would happen if I
typed in um
I type in something like okay so this
one I'm sure we get right famous last
words
okay but if I were to type in something
where those names are out of order we
I'm sure we would not recognize it and
probably shouldn't recognize it actually
what happens if i type in comma um
that's not very
happy
my gosh Alan is that what you would
expect are you happy with that are you
unhappy with that that's a whole bunch
of different questions I'm not surprised
I don't know I mean it's not it's not a
way that people yeah it's not a way
people are gonna enter it and it that's
dangerous a little bit to start
supporting some explicit last name comma
yeah I agree
on the other hand for semantic import
for example that might very well show up
right I mean that's that's what I was
thinking like it's the kind of thing
that I wouldn't I would think might be
useful semantic importer sure
interpreter of person right but ok so
what we've got then is you know what we
don't have right now we don't have a
personal name interpreter right now
so for example that's another you know
Smith comma John what does it do
you
and you know do we have any hope of
cracking these names I wonder if there
are you know do we have a you know maybe
there could be a a German themed um
thing like that
um it will be ambiguous in some cases
for example Martine is an is both a name
and a surname in Spain so it's coming
he's going to be completely impossible
to know right well in the u.s. that's
obviously the case I mean in France if
I'm not mistaken there's a
canonicalization of first names it's
that true is that Ian still here he
would know or can be written it in these
five different ways so again people can
be written in like five different ways
as far as I know I mean what you mean by
kernelization but there's only a fixed
um
person there's only one way to write the
name of this person yes you can can you
can you if you
given two names why is it that in France
for example people often write the
surname in capital letters
to distinguish it from the first name I
guess but why do you need to do that I
mean aren't they always written in a
particular order
no we switch sometimes put the first
last name first without a comma yeah and
also in the case of someone like Hosea
it's useful to know word the first names
and last names beginning I see so that's
why you capitalized
yeah it's cool they often ask us to wear
the last name before because since there
were many repetition in the first name
then it could easily sort I guess my
last name I remembered some part to do a
bit of writing my last name first
because at school they asked did so many
times yeah and you have the confusing
case of having both yes be able to be
firstly the okay well look I think we've
come to no conclusion other than this is
a complicated area um and I think the
the main problem that we have is we
don't completely know what we're trying
to achieve I mean we would like to be
able to canonicalize it may not be
possible and it may be worse to
canonicalize wrong than to leave these
things as strings but I think that the
clear thing that we really want to be
able to do is the mail merge problem of
are these two the same but it is also
possible that that problem is unsolvable
without more information you know if you
have a name and address you have a much
better chance of deciding if they're the
same that if you just have a name all
right well okay we've achieved something
at least with respect to phone numbers
let's at least get that on the way and
okay I think we're wrapping up here soon
I have a last question yes should we
like currently interviewer phone number
returns just a string should we name the
one that returns the dressed object
differently or should we break I don't
know yet let's build the let's some I
mean
we could call it we could start off
calling the new ones structured phone
number or something although that's not
actually our correct convention
structured phone number usually means
the input is structured it means that we
don't call alpha two parts it so it's
already in the case that structure phone
number works for form number so I guess
we should call it phone number object
all right yeah fine let's do that for
now I I'm not convinced that um I'm not
convinced that's ultimately right um boy
people who are on the live stream gosh
we have three live stream meetings
coming up ha at the top of this next
hour is one about function repository
after that is annotations and after that
is visualization so stay tuned for
people who are interested um and um
we'll be back sorry we could come to no
conclusion with respect to yeah this
names thing we need a separate
discussion and probably we should
involve some of the people who deal with
mailing lists of the company to see what
we actually need there as an example
okay so whose whose p.m. in here is it
Sushma yes that's me okay so let's get a
quite separate discussion that involves
some of those people yeah and let's try
it maybe you could try to find out what
they already think they use okay yeah um
okay good stuff talk to y'all soon okay